there's like Lex crying little bugs
crawling on it and I'm not sure we use
it maybe I'll be okay evan is running
naked in the back right now
I am 100 no see I decided to make a
cooking video today today we're gonna
make pork chop with a creamy mushroom
soup
I think this because someone posted on
the Facebook and it looks really yummy
oh my god me yes I said it to Evan okay
let's make this tonight first you have
to make the creamy mushrooms and the in
greeting you will need for the creamy
mushroom part three cloves of garlic and
chopped mushrooms half of the onion two
cups of chicken stock 2 tablespoon of
oil they recommended butter that butter
I like to use Oreo it's more healthier 2
to 3 tbsp of flour 1 cup of light cream
salt pepper and you could garnish with
nutmeg first watch the mushroom you
mince the garlic the onion
now slice the mushrooms just cut in half
in a slices now we're gonna stir the
mushroom onion and guard it together in
this hand so just wait a little bit
until the oil is it's hot then you add
the three ostomy ingredient and stir it
okay so it's hot it's enough so I'm
going to throw the garlic in and then
the mushrooms make sure the onion is
start to get soft and you add two
tablespoons of the flour two cups of
chicken broth add it slowly you can
always add a little bit more flour if
you need to oh it smells good yeah one
cup of cream so one tablespoon of flour
mix it up is it dump it in there
recently we just got this Fitbit and
every day we have to hit our goal
evan has Evans go is 20 K but we can we
hardly reach that Tony go before the
night end so I love it o'clock or 10
p.m. at night
we will run on the spot for an hour just
to fit I would go now we're going to ask
the the cream in here so stir the soup
make sure all the lumps of flour are
gone the soup is almost ready we're
going to add some salt pepper and nutmeg
nutmeg nutmeg nothing you can use 1/2
teaspoon but I'm not really good at
measuring no okay stop it
if you always slap up the thing just to
taste okay to taste
okay
going to pepper okay I'm going to put
this aside and then we will start making
those the foot traps if you understood
to be thickened a little bit you can
shimmy on the others the second stove
can I just let a shimmer for a little
bit enough soup I don't know why I could
have so every day so the next we're
gonna make the pork chop first you want
to go onion and then garnish with this
green onion Chinese onion three quarters
I'm using three parts of garlic ESCO
then just slice the another half of the
onion that's it for this done it I will
say the green ones for to garnish there
porkchop
later on but I'll use of the head the
white part to stir-fry with the garlic
together to give it more flavor pour
some for you in this pan please what's
up I bought it from Costco refuge
it's like Tooting stick at the cousin
and pack this is helping them cutting
whatever you can in half I last my
upside marinated
just ass up right now
[ __ ] up in the medium ie I like to burn
the the outside a little bit before I
over let it simmer simmer for about ten
minutes and we'll see looks good smells
good
mm-hmm I made a salad just to go so we
have some cream to go with the pork
I'm a cow spinach tomato and avocado Hey
it's 10:00 I'm looking forward to try it
ah
nice nice to meet you imagine finding
you a channel like this I am excited
drink juice he is just my kid
let's go yeah it's not very good No
thank you for watching that hope you
enjoyed this video and then give it a
try such a really tasty if you have a
question just leave a comment below and
if you have any requests leave a comment
and I will try to keep your consistent
to have more cooking videos out thank
you 5 3 5 you're cute
your voice is really high okay Kim it's
just that when you get angry it's really
low no Mike this is amazing leave a
comment no I hit my twenty thousand goal
two weeks in a row baby